[Musik]
das altenpflegeheim birkenhof in
salzwedel alle besucher sind ausgesperrt
zum schutz der bewohner was es auf
diesem schild fünf bewohner sind an oder
mit corona gestorben soll der kreis
gestern 29 sind infiziert deshalb fällt
jetzt flach worauf manch eine sich lange
gefreut hat
[Musik]
in die schlagzeilen kommt das heim auch
weil mehrere mitarbeiter hier ungeimpft
zur arbeit gegangen sind wie viele
wissen nicht einmal die
aufsichtsbehörden der heimleiter spricht
von fünf ungeimpften kein interview
anwohner denken über impfpflicht nach
ich bin trotzdem der meinung dass die
patientin auch der fluss sein muss bin
ich der meinung
bin ich unmöglich
also habe ich kein verständnis für
pflegekräfte ohne corona impfung auch
hier im haus am werbellinsee des
branchenriesen halo 1
16 bewohner sind inzwischen tot
insgesamt 61 menschen waren in kuwait
erkrankt nur die hälfte des personals
soll geimpft gewesen sein auch hier
wissen aufsichtsbehörden keine genaue
zahl der leiter soll das haus trotz
positiv test noch betreten haben gegen
ihn laufe ein bußgeldverfahren die
alloheim kette lehnt ein interview ab
und beantwortet unsere fragen nicht die
nachbarn des heims machen sich gedanken
ich bin eigentlich für die impfpflicht
danell wir müssen daran denken dass es
doch eine katastrophe geben kann wenn
diese in pflicht nicht eingeführt wird
denn er sind viele leute die einfach
dagegen sind die sich nicht impfen
lassen wollen und das finde ich nicht in
ordnung
reinhard sager ist landrat des kreises
ostholstein und präsident des deutschen
landkreistags die kreise sind fast
überall für die heimaufsicht zuständig
es ist aus meiner sicht nicht länger in
ordnung dass wir einen anteil von
menschen die in diesen berufen tätig
sind ungeimpft haben das ist für die
pflegeheime eine
unerträgliche situation hier muss
darüber nachgedacht werden eine
verpflichtende impfung vor zu sehen weil
wir nur auf diese art und weise direkt
die älteren menschen schützen kann die
gesundheitsminister sehen das im prinzip
ganz ähnlich vergangene woche beraten
sie in lindau am bodensee
ich finde wer mit verwundbaren alten
menschen arbeitet und die pflegt hat
eine moralische pflicht sich zu impfen
die moralische pflicht allerdings in
eine gesetzliche zu verwandeln daraus
wird hier nichts und so wird auch keine
impfpflicht beschlossen immerhin dürfen
heimbetreiber ihre pflegekräfte
september pandemie bedingt fragen ob sie
geimpft sind wollen sie das überhaupt
wir sind mit diesem examinierte
krankenpfleger verabredet er will nicht
erkannt werden fürchtet berufliche
folgen ich habe in einem pflegeheim lebt
das von über 100 personen 20 mit corona
gestorben sind und das personal war zu
annähernd 50 prozent nicht geimpft das
was ich deshalb weil da offen drüber
geredet wurde im kollegenkreis ich
glaube die pflegedienstleitung wusste
darüber bescheid halten sie eine
impfpflicht für durchsetzbar wenn es
eine impfpflicht gebe in der pflege
würde das die angespannte
personalsituation weiter verschärfen
weil größere teile der pflegenden aus
dem beruf gehen würden besonders
teilzeitkräfte die dazu verdiener sind
und nicht darauf angewiesen sind ich
habe öfters gehört wenn ich gezwungen
werde mich impfen zu lassen gehe ich
vorher aus dem beruf das kann sich die
branche gar nicht leisten urteilt heinz
rothgang er ist professor für pflege und
alterssicherung an der universität
bremen hätten wir eine auskömmliche
personalausstattung könnten wir auch
leichter über beispielsweise eine
impfpflicht sprechen wenn dann einige
den beruf verlassen würden wäre das
nicht so schlimm da wir aber so knapp an
personal sind haben wir uns selbst jetzt
in eine zwangslage gegeben und uns quasi
auch erpressbar gemacht von denjenigen
die sich jetzt nicht impfen lassen
wollen und
deshalb corona macht eigentlich deutlich
man muss an der situation insgesamt
etwas ändern damit man auch für solche
situationen besser gewappnet ist
denn schon vor corinna gab es ein
problem die altenpflege ist
wirtschaftlich einen rendite getrieben
das geschäft geld einsparen lässt sich
in der pflege eigentlich nur am essen
und am personal und genau das ist oft
das wirtschaftliche ziel der
heimbetreiber hinter großen pflege
ketten stehen oft internationale
investmentfonds mit hohem gewinn
erwartungen die erfüllt werden müssen
der pflegeheim rating report 2020 hat
das ausgerechnet ausgewertet wurden die
jahresabschlüsse von 40 großen
pflegeheimbetreiber das repräsentative
öffentlich-rechtliche pflegeheim
erwirtschaftet eine eigenkapitalrendite
von 4,8 prozent
das fr gemeinnützige 3,9 prozent das
privat betriebene hingegen satte
18,2 prozent
dafür wird ordentlich am personal
gespart haben öffentlich-rechtliche
61,1 prozent personalkosten und
freigemeinnützige 62,8 prozent sind es
bei den privaten gerade mal 53 prozent
eine impfpflicht würde die auf kante
genähte personaldecke wahrscheinlich gar
nicht aushalten
urteilt kassenärzte chef dr andreas
kassen bei maybrit illner
neben pflicht ist eine politische
entscheidung das ist keine medizinische
natürlich ist es für mich
selbstverständlich dass wir nicht
patienten kontakte dass sich gm finden
ob man das mit einer impfpflicht regelt
man darf sicherlich nicht völlig
unterschätzen dass wir ohnehin eine
pflegekraft mangel haben also da
eigentlich zu drohen und zu riskieren
dass ein teil dann gar nicht mehr zur
arbeit kommt ich halte das für eine
schwierige entscheidung und auch jens
sparen redet plötzlich klartext wenn wir
jetzt sagen würden im pflicht und 30
prozent sind auf einmal kommen ich habe
die sorge mancher lässt sich nicht
impfen er kommt einfach nicht mehr zur
arbeit
der pflicht denn dann die alten menschen
also gibt es ja zweiter ungeimpfte
pflegekräfte die dann aber bitte
getestet idealerweise täglich fordern
die gesundheitsminister und jetzt auch
die ampel koalition es ist ein
politisches risiko dass dadurch
entstanden ist dass wir uns in der
vergangenheit viel zu sehr festgelegt
haben nicht zu impfen und da muss
politik dann eine rolle rückwärts machen
und wie viel vertrauensverlust das dann
nach sich zieht kann man schwer
abschätzen das ist für politik keine
leichte wahl jetzt weil man sich zu früh
falsch festgelegt habe sachlich wie eine
impfpflicht schon die beste lösung
stattdessen jetzt also testen was das
nutzt oder nicht nutzt hat dieser
krankenpfleger in einem pflegeheim
erlebt die testpflicht bestand
allerdings konnte man auch sagen man
hätte sich zu hause getestet und musste
lediglich die spalte im formular
ausfüllen selbst test kreuzchenmachen
negativ kreuzchen machen ob der test
wirklich stattgefunden hat ist im
nachhinein nicht zu überprüfen weil es
sich um schnelltests handelt die werden
hier hinterher verworfen auf so eine
situation wo zu wenig pflegekräfte da
sind kommt jetzt die korona krise und
wenn sie jetzt die einrichtung dazu
auffordern noch zusätzliche maßnahmen zu
ergreifen test zu administrieren zu
dokumentieren da gehen natürlich einige
einrichtungen schlicht in die knie und
deshalb befürchte ich dass das dann lax
gehandhabt wird weil das personal dafür
einfach nicht da ist
im haus am werbellinsee der alloheim
kette soll regelmäßig getestet worden
sein 16 bewohner sind trotzdem gestorben